all right hello everyone
hello
my name is franz and this is leo's the
prunes we're both core developers for
the sk time open source package
and
today's pi data london tutorial for sk
time will be about how to write your own
estimator so the notebooks for the
tutorial they have been posted on the
slack channel you can also find the link
here on on the screen
and if you have any questions then
helpful core developers of sktime will
also be monitoring the pi data tutorials
channel so including leonidas will be
switching throughout the presentation
and if you have any questions about the
tutorial or how to run the notebooks
just post them there
and
what we are going to do today is going
through the process of writing your own
estimator sktime is a unified framework
for machine learning with time series
it's like it's learn-like it's meant to
be compatible with scikit-learn in the
pi data ecosystem and one of the
properties that it shares with
scikit-learn is easy extensibility so
it's easy for you to write your own
estimators that are compatible with sk
time
even if even in a closed source
situation for instance if you're not
able to share your code you can still
write it in a compatible interface
and leverage the entire framework the
plumbing that sktime provides for you
we are going to follow today the
developer guide on how to write your own
estimator you can also find a link here
if you haven't heard of sk time there
will be a 10 minute introduction first
before we go into the specifics of
implementing your estimator
and you can also find the video
videotape tutorials of generic sk time
use if you haven't seen it and from the
pi data global 2021
tutorial in another tutorial you might
like to check out is the one on
probabilistic and hierarchical
forecasting all right questions you can
ask in the slack channel we'll have
opportunities for questions at the end
as well
let's get started
so
a quick introduction what is sk time as
i've already said is the psyche of learn
like toolbox for
learning with time series it's open
source permissive license python it's
also openly governed and we're not
focused affiliated we're trying to aim
for an equal split between academia
industry and early career contributors
we currently have 19 core developers and
a community council that governs sk time
and integrates with non-focus
everyone can join sk time you can
contribute if you want to
if you want to become a
contributor or a community leader
everyone is welcome
you can join our snack or discord snack
for developer discussion discord for
events the regular community
collaboration sessions on fridays
they're online on discord
so today is a friday you could for
instance join the late session the
schedule is all on slack when you
when you log in we also have a developer
sprint here in london july 11 to july 15
so it's london plus virtual you can
register online by following this link
on eventbrite there is also dropboard or
job opportunities on the horizon which i
wanted to mention so watch the drop
channel we have a mentoring program for
which you can apply on a rolling basis
to start your open source contribution
journey
so scikit-learn what does a psychic
learn like toolbox mean so let's first
look into scikit-learn if you haven't
seen it and by that we also
are going to look into what it means for
sk time to be psychic to learn like so
psychic learn like toolboxes provide a
unified api and workforce following the
object-oriented strategy pattern the
composable allow model building in a
modular fashion and importantly are also
open extensible and contributable
important for today's presentation
extensibility so it means it's easy to
write your own components that are
compliant with the general interoperable
package interface the components that
you've write which are interface
compliant that can be possibly closed
source closed license but they still
interoperate with the general package
and
the package so scikit-learn or sk time
in this case both provide testing
utilities which allow you to check
validity of your custom estimator so
unified api
you might have already seen it if you're
using scikit-learn right you specify
your data you fit
predict evaluate
and
the
unified interface here means that
right step three fit predict evaluate
is all the same for all estimators of
the same type for instance the random
forest regressor you could have chosen a
linear regression model here as well
and
everything else would be the same
modular model building pipelining you
will have also seen probably the
scikit-learn pipeline interface so you
can pipeline a so-called transformer
here the standard scaler which
normalizes your data and the regressor
to form a pipeline which then also
behaves in as per the unified interface
with fit and predicted it exposes the
same methods and the same signature
for use
so in scikit learn of course the
learning task is
learning task related tabular data the
supervised regression classification or
the unsupervised
clustering and dimension reduction tasks
there's a common estimator api and the
estimator apis the mirror specific
learning tasks now for time series what
sk learned what sqlearn does for tabular
learning tasks sktime does that for time
series and a number of challenges for
time series so number one
multiple data formats so you have
already on the conceptual level you have
univariate time series so time series
observations over time on one one
variable if multivariate data so repeat
observation of multiple variables of the
same object over time
you have panel data
that's a collection of time series so
you are have
multiple objects that you're observing
and you have repeated observations of
this multiple objects in your panels
objects or experimental units
collections of time series and also more
you have learning tasks that are also
very
quite substantially forecasting given
the path of a time series you want to
predict this future
you have
time series classifications your time
series are your
different observations that you want to
label as a whole into one class or
another
time series annotation so given a time
series you want to annotate for instance
here's a change point here's a change
point or these are the segments
and so on even within those learning
tasks we have variations so i have
trying to forecast a single time series
or multiple in a panel we have a
hierarchy of time series and so on
there is a relation between these tasks
which is also important
so what we're trying to leverage in sk
time is also the connection between the
tasks trying to solve one
task with a solution for another task a
very
common example so here is
a lot of tasks in in a table you can
also read more about it in the
in the sk time research paper that is on
the archive one very popular um step of
solving task a with a solution for task
b
is a reductive reduction approach to
forecasting so forecasting remember
trying to predict the future of a time
series from its past supervised
regression being trying to predict why
from x as in
as in psychic learn these are not the
same tasks but you can solve forecasting
by a supervised regressor by running a
sliding window and tabulating in a
certain way
and
then you fit your estimated tabulated x
y as you see here in the bottom left and
you can apply it in predict for forecast
if you apply the so fitted regressor to
the
final
window of your time series that you want
to forecast so that's
that's an act of reduction
and it's not the same task what you want
to have
in a clean interface is to expose this
act as an
as an algorithmic wrapper or a
composition act
and
you want also to be able to tune for
instance things like the window length
or the step size in this nci sk time
also allows you to
expose this as a compositor just like
the pipeline object in scikit-learn and
tune over the parameters of this
composition or more specifically in this
case the reduction steps like the
choices from me
sorry there's a there's an audience
question yes
okay so the question is are there also
standard other standard approaches in sk
time of course they are you have auto
regressive models arma arima as well in
sk time and they follow the same
interface right so the so one of the
challenges here would be okay if you do
this in scikit-learn it has a completely
different interface for instance from
stats models arma
or
or
arima whereas in psychic learn in sk
time this is all brought to the same
interface so you've wrapped the cycle
and regressor in your reduction strategy
and it has the same it has precisely the
same interface as
as the arima model that we interface
from stats models which of course is
also a baseline choice that that you
want to try if you forecast
coming to the end of this with sk time
we want to create a unified framework
both ecosystem-wise as well as
software-wise there's multiple learning
tasks here and we try to provide a
unified interface software interface for
the multiple learning tasks for each
learning tasks
so if two algorithms do the same thing
for instance arima and the reduction
strategy using a supervisor requested
they should follow the same base class
interface
and
there's more of course than the software
side to it sktime is also a community
for research right we're connected with
academic centers for instance on
forecasting and time series
classification it is a community so we
have workshops and community engagements
like this everyone can become a
contributor and a community member or a
community leader and we're also trying
to
build educational materials such as this
tutorial which will be videotaped and go
on youtube alongside the other tutorials
that we have videotaped
all right that's the intro to sk time so
i hand over then to my colleague
leonidas
for the first half of the implementing
your own estimator
and if you have any questions
thanks franz
so yeah we'll start with um
the basic way to implement your own
sktime estimator using the extension
templates
and
we'll consider this workshop successful
if by the end of it you can implement
your own estimators use it with
confidence in your projects
and and to get there first we'll start
with a basic developer setup
with jupyter notebooks and an id
we'll use vs code but um anyone can use
whatever they like
and i'll introduce the sktime interfaces
the public side so what the user uses
and the private extension interface
and then we'll go through the basic
steps to implement sk time estimators
we'll do a simple sk time transformer
a simple sktime forecaster and then
we'll also look at the testing utilities
and some debugging as well
and after this section then i'll hand
over back to france for the more
advanced
uh extension staff
so developer setup
in sk time we have a developer guide
that includes very useful information
like installation the dev installation
and
git and github workflows
coding standards like
flake 8
and all that nice stuff how to implement
your own estimator which is what we're
going to do today
and various other things
and this is very useful if you want to
start contributing to the project and
this is also what i followed when i did
my first pull request so i think it was
a very smooth experience
and yeah as i said for this workshop
we'll just we'll jump back and forth
between visual studio code and jupyter
notebooks
and in case you haven't done that
already
it's 9 00 am so it's justified
and
if you want to follow along
you can clone the repo and the link is
in the slack channel
and and then
for the installation you have various
different options you can just install
the requirements pip install dasar
requirements to text
and we recommend you use a virtual
environment to keep your dependencies at
bay so
you can either use
python virtual environment or conda
and i always forget this step but it's
very useful if you want to use notebooks
make them available in a separate
journal as well
so here
for example we can change the kernel to
by the task of time
and life is good
um
so
ask time
what is the public user interface and
what is the private implementer
interface this is the core idea behind
the extension templates and and why it's
easy to write your own sktime estimators
sktime estimators have those two key
interfaces the public and the private
so the public interface has the classic
steps that france showed in the
in the intro so fit and predict
and those are the same for all
estimators that
take care of the same learning task so
for forecasters it will be fit and
predict
for transformers it will be fit and
transform
and the contract so
those the public interface
is shown
and documented in the base class for
every learning task so for example the
base forecaster
the private
interface that
the
extender so us in this case
will use
is denoted by an underscore so the
classic
python convention of
private or protected
methods
and and it's the same
as with the public interface for all
estimators of the same type
and and the contract for this is
documented in the extension templates
which
are available in github and we'll go
through them today as well
you might be wondering okay why do we
have those two interfaces
why can't we just say okay we have fit i
have to implement fit
and why does this weird underscore fit
so
the main reason is
um
there is a bunch of layers that you have
to go through every time you you fit an
estimator
and
and and if we didn't have
this uh approach of the private and the
public interfaces
you would just have to copy paste them
and and it would be
really difficult and annoying to you
know copy paste the same things every
day every time you want to implement a
new estimator
and those can be
check the inputs squares to the right
type because multiple types are
supported convert to this and that or
you know if something works only on
univariate and you you know it
automatically works in panel data as
well because of
the vectorization backend
and this is a very nice schematic of of
the amazing stuff that's happening
between the public and the private
interface there's dragons
good dragons
and there's
a bunch of different stuff that we'll
we'll see as we go through the tutorial
that you just don't have to worry about
so
let's have a look at the public user
interface
if this is not your first time with
sk time and time series you will
probably have seen this
so
um
we're loading
a very popular time series data set
which is
the
australia flights passengers or
something like that
and we're using a naive forecasting
algorithm
to predict it so this naive forecasting
algorithm will say that what happened
last year will happen this year
the forecasting horizon is an important
object for forecasting with sktime
and it has different shapes and forms
but you can fundamentally use a list of
integers and those are the steps you
would like to focus the head
so
we've defined our forecaster
fit
on the time series
predict
on the forecasting horizon you might
notice that the forecasting horizon is
added on the feed step
and sometimes some estimators require
this otherwise you can just add it on
the predict step and we'll go through
that again later on
and what you see here is that the public
interface to get the forecast is just
three lines of work and that's the same
for all forecasting algorithms in sk
time
and
if we look at the docs for the base
forecaster and the public interface
contract and i'm not going to go to the
github but if the link is here for you
if you want to do that and
basically
the
the forecasters have to do
fundamentally three things they can fit
on time series data
they predict the future
and you can update them which is adding
some more
data and then update using that instead
of refitting
and then there's also some convenience
methods like fit and forecast
update and forecast
and so on
here's how
our
name forecast looks like it doesn't look
that bad to me not sure why we call it
naive but
um
yeah
nice and easy so what happens if you
want to implement your own forecasting
algorithm so you want to do better than
naive or whatever is out there in ski
time or other packages
um so in sktime we have private methods
as we said that in the extension
template
you just need to fill in
so let's have a look at one at one of
the extension templates for forecasting
and
here we go
so we deep we differentiate between
extension templates we have simple
extension templates where you just have
to implement the bare minimum
in this case it would be fit and predict
and we also have advanced extension
templates where you have to implement
um more fancy stuff like
update
and
predict
intervals and so on
so
if you if you read through the docs
it basically tells you what you need to
do
so you just have to go in
change the names write the docs strings
and change these tags we'll go through
the tags in more detail later
here we go
thanks franz so
there's also to do's
on what you need to do as comments in
the code and
when you do that
feel free to remove them
um because
the code would look
ugly and and there's explanations about
what everything does
so here for example for the init you
need to add any hyper parameters and
components to the constructor so
if we would implement
a naive forecasting algorithm that has
that's a seasonal knife forecasting
algorithm we would need to add
decisionality for example
and then
the next thing to do is to implement the
fit logic in the private fit method
you will never touch the public fit in
this template
which is very nice
same for predict
and finally if you want to use the
testing framework that we'll see later
you can implement the get test
parameters that creates the various test
parameters that you can use
so
we saw what we need to implement
and where so if you want to implement
something you just copy paste that
extension template into your code into
your packets you have a skit time
installed you can start
what happens between fit and private fit
so
we can look and examine the plumbing
layer
using
the excellent debugging utility make
mock estimator made by one of sk times
most illustrious contributors
me
and so make mock estimator is is a new
utility we introduced it's a testing
slash debugging utility that adds
logging to internal methods calls
and
it also shows you what
the inputs to these methods were
i think it can work with
any python class
so
you can see you can test that for
yourselves
and
so we make a mock estimator based on the
name forecaster so
now we can see what happened
when we called fit
so
what happens is
first you call fit and then a bunch of
other stuff happens
and finally the method you implement
this code
so what are these methods
so first it's the fit you called
then
after
you call fit we reset the state so start
clean
get the parameters of the estimator
check the forecasting horizon and coerce
it to the right type so before we had
the list but on the back end this will
become a forecasting horizon object
get the tags that we saw so those are
useful information about the logic of
the plumbing layer
check the inputs
and set the cutoff which is the last
the most recent time point in the
training data and then finally
and
use the private feed that we have
implemented
so
you can see for example and we'll see
that in more detail later on that
there's a lot of data types conversions
so
that happened between the public
interface and the private interface
and again that's stuff that you don't
have to worry about
same for predict so when you call
predict there's a bunch of stuff
happening so first
um you have to check that the algorithm
is fitted otherwise we throw an error
check the forecasting horizon
and get the tags check the inputs and
finally
predict
so to summarize what we've learned so
far sk time estimators have two key
interfaces a public user interface
feed predict
a plumbing layer between to avoid copy
pasting code
boilerplate errors all that sales
and a private user interface
underscore fit and underscore predict
and
as an extender of sktime you just need
to implement the content in the private
user interfaces and set the correct tags
and arguments in fit and predict
and
to appear in the favorite format
so
now we'll go through implementing our
first estimator so
here is a link to the extension
templates that you can copy paste from
github
at the high level the steps are identify
what you want to do you want to make a
transformer a forecaster
classifier
copy the extension template
complete the extension template run the
test rate
and then
keep going until the tests pass
and we'll go through the test suite in
detail a bit later
so for the first example we'll implement
a min max scalar
transformer and
we'll use this the transformer templates
to implement the minmax scalar and
and here is what it looks like so
you can notice that
the number of airline passenger
passengers is now bounded by 0 and 1
which is what our min max scalar
transformer should be doing
and we can also invest transform it back
to what it was is also um for those of
you who are not uh
who are a bit suspicious in a third
statement that make sure we're okay
and so let's have a look at the
transformer extension template and then
we'll try to fill it in
and
here we go
so
let's have a look so first it's
recommended to write our doctrine so
we'll do that fill in any parameters
once those are finalized
we'll need to check the tags so
what is the scientific type of the time
series or site type as we say it in sk
time
that our transformer is supposed to work
with is it series a panel
multivariates what's the output of our
transformers does it return back a
series does it return a panel something
else
um
and various other different tabs what's
very important here is the inner m types
so
what the inner m types are
and again
france will go through this in
great detail on the next part
are
guarantees about what
type will reach the private method so
for example you can
use a pandas data frame for
a univariate time series but you can
also use
panda series or maybe something else
numpy array
what
what the inner m-type guarantees is that
when
that series reaches your private method
it will be the specified type in this
tag so you can start with a numpy
array as your inputs and then it will
turn into a pandas data frame so you
only have to worry about
pandas data frames
so
and we'll just copy paste this extension
template i'm not going to do it live too
risky with my lag
um
and
we'll implement the private fit and the
private transform
and maybe the investment form as well to
do the min max scaling
yes
good question so the there is an integer
index that is supported
um
yeah so it's always interpreted as an
integer it's not like it's not time but
you know it's still a sequence with
um
that's ordinary
um
but yeah that that was a good question
um so let's look at the simple
transformer
imagine that we copy-pasted um
the extension template change the name
instead of my transformer it's now min
max scalar
say what it needs to do so
the main max scaler applies the
transformation that ensures that series
is bounded by zero and one could do
better with a stock string but
it's okay so
our site type input is going to be
series we'll go into output series so
it's going through the tags
it is an instance wise transformer so it
works on a series by series basis
it has the capability of inverse
transforming it works only on univariate
time series
and
and you can see that i've changed the
inner m type to be
a panda series just because i'd like to
work with panda series for this one
and
so i'll skip through the rest
and go straight to in it so i mean max
scalar doesn't have any hyper parameters
so we just go like this
and
here is the private fit
that we made
so as part of the private fit
we it's nice to change the dock string
to say that okay
the
x in this transformer is guaranteed to
be a panda series
so
it's useful for developers who will see
the private interface at some point to
know that and why
is ignored it's just here for interface
compatibility with other transformers
that might need y
so in the private fit we just
save the mean and the max of
the input data
and then that's it so the next step is
to implement the transform
the private transform so again same
thing
and change the dog strings to what's
expected
and then
some
uh saving of attributes of the
transformed x and y those are not used
but it's just uh i guess nice to have
them there
and and then transform your ex
with the logic that the min max scaler
likes so
x minus the minimum divided by the
maximum minus the minimum and then just
return the transformed x
the inverse transform is also
implemented in this one you don't have
to implement it but
we implemented this for this example so
it's just multiply
the transformed data by
max minus min and then add them in and
also because we'd like to use this in
the testing framework
we
return an empty dictionary which means
just use the default parameters for the
tests
so
we've seen what we implemented
and now
it's time to check that our transformer
oh that's strange
we might need to rerun this
let's see
yeah all that although all that is
intentional
we are rerunning it it's really fast
because ascii time is great
it's okay
it's under control
go ahead friends
you need to be fast because we fixed it
okay no no no stand-up comedy needed
so
sorry about that
um
we we tricked you we implemented the
bagi transformer
and just to make it fail on the test
framework
so
um yeah
so we have a test framework uh there is
a tech estimator utility function um
i think developed by france which is a
very nice function for
and marcus
which is a great
tool for the extenders to make sure
that the new estimator is going to be
compatible with the sktime api
so
you just need to import it from sktime
so from ascii time utils estimator
checks import tech estimator
and
that when you run it the results will be
stored in a dictionary
and you can also print or raise the
exemptions if you say return exception
is true then
it will print exceptions not reason so
we see here that
our estimator has failed
and we can see where
right so
it felt on the test test methods do not
change state
mean max scalar transformer fit
transform series univariate transform
so
we can get more details about this
if we just look at the dictionary here
we just
you know print it in a workshop friendly
way so
the error message is the min max scalar
changes dict so it changes the state
during the transform step
the reason location of the discrepancy
is
it has those new keys x transformed x
min sorry transformed x bin and
transform the x max
so
a requirement from sktime
is that
transform
predict and that stuff do not change the
state and that's key to prevent leakages
and other horrible stuff
and so you know the methods that
typically change state are fit update
and so on
so we can fix that luckily we know
exactly what the problem is
so
here
in the new transform step we will just
not do that
and those were useless anyway
so then if we rerun the testing
framework all tests are passing
and we're confident that
our
new transformer is compatible with api
in
all ways
so now let's look at the simple moving
average yeah go ahead
ah yes you're right so there's a that
that might be a mistake on my side uh
you you're saying that fitted parameters
are denoted by
uh
you know the name of the attribute and
an underscore on the on the right
instead yes so i think that's correct
yes
maybe we should write some testing
good stuff we recommend i think
implementers
so feel free to make a pull request
um
yeah so for a simple forecasting
algorithm we we chose to do to implement
a simple moving average
people call this simple moving average
because
a a real moving average is not that
simple
so what a simple moving average does is
you ask it to give you a forecast that
is simply the mean of the last
five observations and and here is how it
looks like so we say use the last five
observations on our
lovely airplane passengers data set to
predict the next
three steps
okay so
to do that
again we just copy paste
the simple forecasting extension
template
um
and then imagine that this is copy
pasted
we then
and implement what
the to do's are there so for the simple
moving average we'll write a dog string
the simple moving average has one
parameter which is
how many how many of the
most recent past observations will you
use for the mean so that's window length
in our case
we will change the tags to meaningful
tags for this estimator so it's going to
work on univariate time series it
ignores exogenous variables so
it doesn't use for example
inflation
future inflation for predicting airplane
passengers so that's what exodus
variables are
it doesn't handle missing data the inner
type for the time series is a series
it does not require the forecasting
horizon
on the feet step some algorithms will
for example france talked earlier about
using machine learning
for
time series using the reducing strategy
so if you do that you can for example
fit a new
random forest regressor for every time
step you want to predict in the future
so the algorith the
algorithm will need to
know how many time steps you want to
predict in the future in advance because
otherwise it can't fit a different one
for every time
and
it can't predict intervals because it's
simple
so
again here's the logic
we
we will um give a warning that y has
less time steps than the window length
and the full series will be used if
if that's the case
um and otherwise we just take the mean
of the last of the most recent
observations up until the window length
and then
don't don't
highlight this again but i did the same
mistake
storing it in this format
and
so we store that forecast value it's
going to be the same for all the steps
and when we predict we need to just make
the index of the output series so just
the index is the forecasting horizon to
absolute so the absolute dates not
relative to the cutoff
and just return the same value for all
the dates
we will also
implement a few different testing
parameters
of different window lengths just to
cover everything all the edge cases
and
and then finally once we do that
we will go to the testing framework
to check if everything works and in this
case
and there's no bugs so all the tests
pass
and
and we can go on using that whatever we
want
compatible with ascii time
api
so
some credits
me and franz created this notebook
the extension templates were created by
france and the extension guide
the base class is a group effort by
marcus
i don't know biggo's first name um he
doesn't want this to be disclosed
so big o
uh france uh
they'll be angry at me later
and
and now uh back to france for the
advanced section of this workshop
all right
all right
so
notebook number three okay
so we've seen how to use the simple
forecaster and transformer extension
templates and i now just wanted to show
some
advanced patterns
that might arise for instance if you
want to implement probabilistic
forecasters or
transformers forecasters for
hierarchical data or composite
estimators such as pipelines or
estimators which have other estimators
inside another example would be
the
reduction estimator that
that wraps an sk learn estimator for
instance
and we'll also look into automated
testing so how you can integrate
with
the
with your test suite
all right
so three examples in this notebook
right so update and
probabilistic
functionality in the forecaster first
so how to use the
full extension template all right so
we'll look in in a moment at the
extension template thing again to
remember
from the basic notebook is we have the
public interface
the public user interface the private
extender interface the extender
interface is the one against to
implement
the contract of which you need to
fulfill if you implement your estimator
and the public methods will have
in this case will be update and predict
underscore
interval quantiles and so on so sk time
forecasters currently have four public
interface points for
uh probabilistic predictions in
including interval or fully
distributional predictions
there's one interface point for
updating say in a stream an online
setting and the general
[Music]
picture is the same
to the public side methods you can pass
a number of different data formats
whereas in the inner methods you can
assume specific data formats
that
that you will see there and using your
implementation
similarly right to the public interfaces
you can pass things like alpha or
coverage for the interval quantile
forecasts as numbers or lists in the
interface in the inner interface this is
always guaranteed to be a list for
instance so the inner interface is
typically easier to implement against
and checks have already been done
conversions have already been done
so
maybe one also minor thing specifically
about the advanced forecasting interface
there's also defaulting happening here
then so there's default behavior
implemented if you implement one of the
four probabilistic forecasting methods
than usually depending on the method
itself of course but the others or some
others might automatically be
implemented for instance if you make if
you know how to make quantile
predictions then mathematically also
know how to make interval predictions
and you need to implement only one of
the two and the others to become
implemented through assumption of a
normal distribution which may or may not
always be accurate but you get you get
this as default behavior
so let's look into the
advanced forecasting extension template
and
at the top you have more things in
listed so this is
similar it follows the
pattern of the simple forecasting
extension template all extension
templates look similar
but of course you also have
a list of other methods that you could
be implementing and what we're going to
do is we're going to implement all the
optionals and see what happens so we're
going to implement the underscore update
so we're going to make a non-trivial
online or stream update we're going to
implement one of the interval
predictions in a silly fashion and we're
also going to implement get fitted
params so that's similar to
get params so getting the hyper
parameters but in this case it returns
the fitted parameters as a dictionary
all right so let's let's see what we
need to implement
now
um right there's the tags maybe we
remember okay always look first at the
tags
is there anything we need to change
maybe there's
nothing we need to change maybe there's
something we need to change i do not
know but we might see later that
hopefully the test will tell us if we
forgot something
there
fit and predict we have already
implemented so what we could do now of
course we take the estimator we've
already implemented and then copy over
just the methods we additionally want to
implement or we can start over
with the full extension template
and copy over the parts from the
estimator we have already implemented
usually copying the parts from the
extension template into an existing
forecaster if you want to implement more
methods is safer
right
so update here we need to implement here
is the generic guarantees so of course
we want to change this to all y is a
pandas
panda series
um
in in the final doc string
all right so this these are so update
predict signal it's a default
implementation we don't need to worry
about that so predict quantiles is the
function
is the private method for
quantile predictions and here we see
okay we get
fh and x so what we also see in predict
forecasting horizon optionally and the
an exogenous data which we'll ignore in
this case
the important input is the alpha so the
list of
quantile points at which we want to have
the forecasts the return needs to be a
partners data frame in a specific format
with a multi-index
right so the
column has a multi-index which has
possibly variable names
and the second level has the values of
alpha
being passed
the entries are the quantile forecast
the rows are the absolute indices where
we make a forecast at
it's a predict interval
we don't need to implement this because
in base class this has a default
implementation so if we would now copy
this over if we would now copy predict
interval over but don't fill it in then
the estimator would break and the test
would tell us but of course we're not
going to do that that's also a popular
bug
and
finally we have get fitted params
that needs to return a fitted parameter
dictionary that does not have at the
moment this public private split but
there is still one element of
boilerplate
um which we need to watch out for
i'm not going to tell you at the moment
what it is because the tests are going
to tell us in in a moment so this is um
the full extension template for
forecasters and now let's
pretend we start filling it in
so what we're going to so in in the
final thing of course you want to change
the
dog strings and also that of your
forecaster but for the purpose of this
tutorial we left them in so you can see
you can compare the to-do's
to what is actually written there
right so the so we want update in proba
and also get fitted params
and we fill in here the update so it's
update of a moving average this with a
with a
fixed look back and i started to
implement it and i noticed it's
a bit more complicated than you would
think because there is three different
cases depending on the length of the new
update data and the full data so the
window could be smaller or longer
than
the then either of these windows which
gives you three cases that you need to
take care of
but each case is really simple
arithmetic formula and
as i said just to make all
psychics learn developers here angry in
this audience the
underscores at the front
now
for predict quantiles we've done
something very silly so all the quantas
are just the same number which means
the estimator is absolutely certain that
the prediction will be the point
prediction which is maybe not a good
thing to do but for the purpose of this
tutorial
to do something illustrative what we
have to do is just get the data in the
right format so create a multi-index the
multi-index that is supposed to be
returned here
so it's univariate we can use the
we should actually be using the fill in
capital letters quantiles and the second
level in the columns is the alpha at
which we predict
and that also automatically
will then by defaulting
fill in the predict interval and the
predict variance method and all
and for get fitted params
we return one parameter called forecast
value
and we read out the fitted param here
so that will also return a dictionary
okay so far so good the test params we
can actually leave the same because in
the tests these still cover
the different cases of okay is the
window no larger or not than
say the update batch or the full batch
all right so now let's see what happens
and okay this is importing from
uh from from a module that's called
buggy so you might expect some things to
happen
and so we have three test cases
so three test estimators coming from the
three parameter sets
and they all
come back
with a failed test
so two failed tests each test spread in
tag and test raise is not fitted error
now in order
so you can look at of course the error
message
of each and sometimes this is helpful
sometimes it is unspecific
the first test
if you look at the results remember this
is a dictionary returned by the utility
check estimator and we look at the
results there
we the key is simply the
pi test rings or test name and fixture
combination in square brackets
we look at it and it says okay it does
implement probabilistic forecasting oh
but we forgot to set the flag capability
print in
the
in the tags
so the implementation is actually
inconsistent with how we set the tags so
what we need to do to make this go away
is to set this to true so also in terms
of the tag interface we have this
correctly set in accordance with in
implementation namely that we have
actually a predict interval and a
predict quantiles function that has
meaningful content
the second one
gives this so it gives an attribute
error
so the exception itself is not too
useful to look at it says okay
the
we're trying to access an attribute here
namely the forecast value
and
that's a bit strange so that's not very
clear
now what we can do
is look at the trace back and test so
now we need to find out well what does
the test actually test i think it's a
good example now
of course what we could do in the next
month is to make this specific error
message clear and we always appreciate
pull requests or reports if you think
the error message is not clear but i
picked this as an example because
there's a lot of tests running and not
all of them have really clear error
messages and invariably at some point
you might encounter if you run check
estimator an error message that is not
very clear
so what you can do in that case to find
out what's wrong here
usually you just need to look at the
traceback as well as the test
so if we now go into the test so that
means searching for test raises not
fitted error
either on say via the github web
interface of the sktime repository or if
you have a local clone of it you can
search in the
in in your
developer ide
or what you could also do if you really
don't know what it's about you just go
on to the developer slack and then the
contributor's channel asks okay
i test my estimator and i get this weird
your error can can you help me or you go
to one of the community collaboration
sessions and usually some helpful
developers will be there and you can
screen share and you can drill down into
the problem now in this case
the traceback of the test is useful of
course you can run it with the pi test
if you have the full developer set up
you have a local clone and you have pi
test running but you can also get it
from check estimator because as leonidas
has previously said right if you switch
this return exceptions flag to false so
instead of returning it in the returning
the exceptions in the dictionary it's
going to raise them the first one it
encounters and you can also subset the
tests or the fixtures by the arguments
tests to run or fixtures to run
to get the trace back right there in
your interactive developer console and a
python
console
and there you see okay what what is
happening
so we act it's actually happening when
get fitted params is being run
it's trying to access this self
underscore forecast value
when it's not set yet
now
that's interesting because
if you look at it this is not misspelled
so okay it has the underscore at the
start but it's consistently wrong
so it's that can't be the problem and if
you look into the test
which i i think
can't do or can i do this right here
to print the test somehow
yeah i guess i can't do this because we
don't have a clone but you can just
search and what it will say is
this test test raises not fitted error
is testing what if you call
any of the
non-state changing methods like update
predict or get fitted params is also on
the list and the estimator is not fitted
it should raise an error and the problem
is it does not
and not fitted error specifically and
the problem is it doesn't raise an
outfitted error it raises an attribute
error
right so this one is relatively subtle
but once we understand that
from the test right it's
it's not a hundred percent clear in the
extension template and i said you might
encounter occasionally that the
extension template is not a hundred
percent clear and that but that way you
can still diagnose it as i have shown
you so what you need to do
is is either that or you could also do
this if not
self is fitted and this is probably
nicer if you do this
if you do it that way
oops so i cannot this is a mac
so we could also do this instead
and this is going to have the same
effect
all right so what this one's it still
has this old boiler plate
and there's only one
piece of boilerplate for get fitted for
arms but it needs always needs to be
there so maybe if someone wants to make
the first pull request to sk time
perhaps these two lines should be in the
extension template for get fitted params
as said one example of
imperfect documentation you can track
these things down by using two things
a check estimator traceback or the full
test framework
check estimator use it with
return exceptions equals false and
searching for the test and seeing what
it does
all right
and
along
the way we've also learned about
the full extension template for
forecasters
so some caveats
all right again
if you if you follow the extension
template it's important to look for
differences in signatures of public and
private methods
all right so private methods usually
have a simpler interface but this also
means they have a different interface so
if you for instance have been using
predict interval and you always just
pass a number and you expect the private
interface to have also a float for alpha
instead of a list then you might
encounter an error so
it's usually well documented hopefully
in the dock strings of the private
methods in the extension template
as well as in in the base class of
course which also has
abstract versions of that what what
these private methods are doing what the
contract is that you need to implement
against
another example f8 is guaranteed to be a
forecasting horizon so if you always
have been using lists or numpy arrays
then
you can't assume this anymore in the
private method you need to use the
forecasting horizon and the forecasting
horizon is a central class which also
has its own documentation we won't go
into details about it here
and the other example obviously and
that's part benefit
partly occurs
that the y and the x are going to be in
the specified formats in the x
and the y inner m type more and more
about that below
further
right if you implement option methods a
common mistake is that the capability
tags have not been correctly set
so
some tags they're silent some tags are
only really there for findability some
control the behavior
of
of the estimator
and the check estimator usually will
tell you
if the tags are incorrect but not always
further one minor detail right so if you
you have an estimator if you say in
predict interval you want to call
predict
it's usually better to call private
methods from within private methods and
not the public methods because in the
private methods the conversion has
already been done so let's say you want
in your predict quantiles you want to
get the point prediction because that's
the mean
or the median
of a distribution that you predict then
call self underscore predict from within
self underscore predict interval and not
self
predict interval without the underscore
as ourselves predict without the
underscore from within self underscore
predict interval
all right
next topic tags tags and data types
so as an implementer typically you can
leave the tags as they are they are
sensible defaults
so
the conversion tags for the internal
data types
they will typically convert to something
in pandas as a pandas in with a specific
additional
assumptions like for panel data having a
row multi index
of instance and time or for a single
series just panda series or pandas data
frame so these are typically
[Music]
set sensibly
but of course if you want to interface
something right if you if you want to
use sk time as an interface layer
or
let's say
you need the data in a specific format
internally you should be aware how the
tags work
and how the data formats strings and
specifications work in sk time
generally there's three high-level types
of tags
so one type of tag tells you about the
capability that the estimator has or
doesn't have that's very useful also for
for inspection so the sktime registry
allows you to retrieve estimators allows
you to tell
the all estimators utility okay now find
me all forecasters that can make a
probabilistic prediction for instance or
now find me all transformers
that
do something non-trivial with with
hierarchical data
the property and type tags so they tell
you about what inputs and outputs the so
what inputs say an estimator can handle
what outputs it produces
these are
properties they are descriptions rather
than
instructions
and the final one is behavioral tags
they are instructions
as in for instance
inside the inside the inner methods so
in underscore fit and so on i want to
see a numpy array i want to see a pandas
data frame so that tells
the boy the the plumbing layer
i want to
i want you to convert my inputs to the
sensor that for example
there's some related methods that you
should know so get tags and get tagged
we have seen them in the print out that
is called in the
in the plumbing layer a lot
it's also it can also be used for
retrieval or property inspection of
estimators say if you want to loop over
the estimators and on and call
probabilistic prediction only for those
that
that can do probabilistic prediction
now as an implementer you should also be
aware of set tags and clone tags so
these are for developer use and they're
relatively rarely used by developers i
just want to mention them because for
instance in composites you may want to
set tags dynamically in initialization
so for instance if you're a pipeline and
you want to say you want to set the tag
of the capability can this deal with
missing data you may want to check that
either everything in the pipeline can
deal with missing data or there is at
some point an element that removes
missing data
but typically you you will not use them
if you implement estimators just good to
be aware of
now
examples right we've seen this already
in extension template you run git tags
you get all the tags of a given
estimator
and for forecasters right the behavioral
tags are these four
so x inner m type x interim type the two
most important ones what do you convert
your data in underscore and underscore
methods
then fit is empty
tells you in so both in forecasters and
transformers is there anything in fit or
do you want to skip it
and force index type
is a check
it gives you
uh it gives you an error message if the
index of a pandas object is not of a
certain type it's it's rarely used
because most estimators in sk time
actually do an index conversion
instead of
throwing an error message transformers
have a bit more the reason for that is
the transformers are more polymorphic
so transformers can output as we have
seen
series they can output a panel they can
output a
set of
scalars when you pass a series of
feature extraction from a series with
output scalars
uh
most transformers for time series output
to time series so for instance
differencing or imputation in some like
bootstrapping or sliding windows they
even output the panel and even also the
inputs can be different so due to this
polymorphism there are more tags which
we need to control why these are the
property tags so what's the input what's
the output
uh the instruction or behavioral tags
right there's again the inner m types
and
then
two skip tags so skipping fit or
skipping inverse transform you see
they're not entirely uniformly named the
tags but of course it's it's a bit of a
deprecation nightmare to get the more
uniformly named it will happen
eventually
okay
tags to summarize your three types of
tags capability property behavioral as
an implementer you need to primarily be
wary of and care about the behavioral
tags
and these x inner m type y inner m types
right they are
specifying a format specification and
that's a string and that's a
string that refers to one of the
specifications inside sk time
namely to what is what i'm not going to
explain in this section
so sk time has a concept a two their
concept of in-memory specifications
sk time aims to not have one specific
format for time series because we know
our users have different opinions about
what the best input format is for time
series and output format and if you have
collections of time series it gets even
more
diverse so instead we
collect specifications and support
multiple specifications by
wrapping or conversion
and that is done
through the concept of psi types and
m-types or scientific types and machine
types
scientific types also are called
sometimes abstract data types so these
are different
conceptual types on the mathematical
level so is it a time series so an
object
which which collects observations
indexed of the time index or any indexed
1d index observations so it's the
abstract data type behind the pandas
partner series or pandas
data frame
and also a numpy 2d array
could represent that abstract data type
although of course the
the interpretation of a 2d numpy array
is not clear whereas the m-type the
machine type or the
concrete type is the specific
representation that is being used for
the abstract type
so example
a series coupled with capital letters
is a scientific type in sk time
and a time series can be represented by
a panel's data frame by a panda series
and a numpy
array with additional specifications
those specifications you can read in the
data read up in detail on the
data types and data format specification
part of the documentation
now
for
for forecasting for transformation for
time series the three most important one
are series panel and hierarchical series
a single time series panel a collection
of time series a flat collection and
hierarchical is a hierarchical
collection of time series so where
hierarchies we can have more than one
level of hierarchy
examples for the panel
so in for a single time series the
representation is relatively clear
for collections of time series you have
a lot of different data types some and
some are preferences of certain
communities associated with time series
specific learning tasks so for instance
if you do time series classification you
might like more the 3d numpy
representation or the nested pandas data
frame representation whereas if you do
forecasting you might find a row
multi-indexed pandas data frame a more
natural representation of a collection
of
of your time series
you can look up the explanation in the
entire register
of
machine types and abstract data types
in the
data types module m-types register so
for the implementer what is important to
know is this string
right so if you enter this string the
m-type string in the
y-inner m-type tag what is what you get
so what you get is a y or an x that is
compliant with the specification here on
the right
and or the more or the more detailed
specification in the data types and data
conventions
so here's two examples pd multi-index
for a collection
of for a collection of time series this
is the pd multi-index m-type so columns
are the variables and the rows is a
multi-index 2d two-level multi-index
with instances and time points time
points being the last one they do not
need to have specific names the levels
the same
collection of time series is also
represented in this
3d numpy array and
escape time considers them as equivalent
abstract objects
so you can use for instance also the
convert
to function
to convert between
the types the representations and this
all happens automatically in the
plumbing layer
so
let's have a look at
another advanced example so let's say we
want the min max scaler
to take the minimum and maximum
across
multiple time series
and not just for individual time series
so sk time has automated vectorization
for a panel and hierarchical data so
collections of time series
and that means
what it will do is it will apply a
transformer that is implemented only for
a single time series to the individual
time series so the scaling will happen
to individual time series let's say if
we have this hierarchical data container
and we apply the min max scalar that we
implemented so it has here values four
five six and four fifty five six in the
first series here it will scale the four
to zero and the six to one and the
second the four to zero and the 55 to
one but what we might want to do in this
case actually we want to scale the 55
everywhere to one and the four
everywhere to zero now the default
behavior is as i've said
scaling happens individually per
per time series instance but if you want
to have this happen overall
then
then you need to change something in the
text so you need to
in the tags in the x
inner m type
you need to have at least a hierarchical
data type
so the
the one hierarchical machine type is
this string
so
it's the type in which this data
container is
and if we look at the extension template
all right that means we need to fill in
the x inner m-type tag
with
a hierarchical m-type
or preferably a list of m types which
cover multiple scientific types so we
still want to work it for series and we
also want to work it to work for
hierarchical data types now we're a bit
short on time so i just quickly show you
the buggy version
so the buggy version is we just fill in
the hierarchical m-type
so we do that
it works as we intend for the
hierarchical data container
it still works for single series but in
the tests it will fail if you par
because if you pass a data frame it will
fail because we have assumed the series
inside
so
instead
you need to fill in a list and if you
fill in a list of m types then it will
search is there something on the list
which is of the same
abstract type so hierarchical or series
and then convert
to
if it's if the current m-type is on the
list it will not convert
if something of the same side type is in
the list it will convert to the first
occurrence in the list and in this case
we have put
[Music]
the machine types to cover the three
time series scientific type series panel
and hierarchical and that no longer
raises an error so just skim over this
but you can of course look into the
failure and you can look into the
example
if you look at the notebooks
right so the explanation is okay we need
to deal with two cases it has a pandas
multi-index or it has a simple index
all right last but not least
a composite estimator
so as in scikit-learn
you can
pass
estimators to the argument as an
argument to the constructor that makes
the estimator composite also
conceptually
as recognized by for instance nested
parameter inspection via getparams which
you might be familiar also from
scikit-learn we are fully compatible
with scikit-learn there
so uh if you pass an sk time or a
psychic learn estimator as an argument
to as an l2 sk time estimator
and it's a default
so it's by default always an estimator
or none then you will also get
the nested parameter inspection
from the getparams method
and
what you need to look out for here
multiple things right
components should be passed to
constructor
so you expect an object there not a
class
the object then should be written to
self again
a parameter of the same name attribute
of the same name
you shouldn't fit the object that you
pass it needs to be considered as a
blueprint conceptually so you need to
clone the object and fit the clone do
not fit
the argument of the constructor
possibly you need to set dynamic tags if
properties of the composite depend on
properties of the components you can
leave that empty
for the descriptive tags it it won't
make much of a difference
in methods
so usually you want to call the
components methods from the composites
methods
always call the public methods of the
component not the private methods
so always interface the outer layer of
the component
from
the inner methods of the composite
finally the non-state changing method
should not cause state-changing methods
of the component
because you do not want to change any
state not of the composite not of
components in the non-state changing
method
predict transform and others
all right so let's have a look at
composite moving average and what we do
here is okay we fit
so we give it another argumented
transformer
we feed the transformer
on
the data we see in fit and after we
forecast we apply the transform of that
transformer in the forecast
right so
um
right so we write the transformer to
self
okay
then
in fit we fit the transformer on the
data we all see
and in predict here we add this line we
transform the prediction
okay all good or not well the file is
called buggy so maybe there is some bug
in here we can ask again check estimator
and it says oh no the
test fails test fit does not override
hyper params
and
what happens here oh the estimator
should not change and the parameter so
exponent transformer that's in the get
test params okay it's the
transformer so one of the examples of
course needs to have a transformer that
is not none or of course we will not
test
the case where we have a component in
there
and
so we run the test and in that case
that's the only case within transformer
that's not none or
it's changing the state and well what
did i just say right we should clone the
transformer we should not fit the
transformer we pass to the init so this
is a very common mistake right but
it's also easily fixed
by running clones you can run
scikit-learn clone
or you can also run the
any sk time estimator has a method clone
which does the same thing
as you can do it either way
and then of course you fit oh look
underscore at the end is anyone happy
about underscore at the end yeah
and of course you do what you do with
the clone and not with the object you
pass to in it
all right
so now it works
again some caveats
right as i've already said when you call
methods of the components use the public
ones always clone components
also important it's quite subtle don't
overwrite conversion tags the
instruction tags of the components
dynamically it might seem
appealing to do that because then you
avoid conversions sometimes but if you
do then it it invites a lot of pain
usually so try to avoid conversions by
for instance
making your composite polymorphic or you
can pass a list of m types
and
if you pass a list then it's an or right
if you want to pass numpy and and pandas
you just put them on a list instead and
instead of copying your component tags
and one very subtle thing in update so
even if you do nothing
in update you may still need to call the
update of the components because update
does things like update the timestamp of
the most recently seen data
now very
and that's it about
composites very quickly about test
framework
so the easiest way of course
is import check estimator and make it a
part of your test
important thing
you need to run it in the version that
raises exceptions instead of returning
the dictionary
because only if it raises the exception
the test will fail and it means setting
the return exceptions
flag to false there's a there's advanced
way to integrate with your testing
framework including inheritance you can
read all about it in the developer
documentation
on the testing framework i will not go
into that in detail either so summary
ascii time is extensible cycle to learn
like you can build extension templates
to build your own sktime compatible
components there's a full testing
integration with which which you can use
in your ci cd you can use check
estimators or
not shown today
inherit from the classes in the ascii
time testing framework and sktime
compatible components even if they are
in your own package they will typically
work out of the box with the sk time
framework machinery like pipelines and
reduction
all right that's it for the content um
we have five minutes for questions maybe
you need us you want to come up um
here quickly so as we've said everyone
can join we have a developer sprint july
11 to 15. there's going to be a
maintainer role advertised in the jobs
channel
and we have a rolling basis mentoring
program to which you can apply we have
currently google summer of code running
and also a number of work streams you
could show another quite interesting
in the developer sprint if you want to
join that here is a qr code
that i'm now trying to
display in a way that oh no
there you go questions yes
then
do you have a polarization
parallelization support
for your
pipelines
that are implemented inside
so some some composites have
dropped the parallelization support some
don't it's inconsistent currently
and contributions on that front are
obviously very much appreciated make a
pull request join the developer slack
and
help us making our pipelines more
efficient
okay thank you
well everything is obviously been very
clear
if not i'd say uh let's give a round of
applause thank you
[Applause]
so if you're not familiar with sk time
you can watch the
general tutorial it's on youtube pi data
global 2021 link is
in
the
github repository as well as on the
sktime main repository and if you want
to join the developer sprint it's here
in london
tickets are available
july 11 to 15. register online via
eventbrite thank you very much
all right we're gonna take a 30 minute
break and then start next round thank
you